50 years after apollo we have a new
program
so what we're doing is we're going to
mars and the moon is the way to get to
mars so the moon is the proving ground
it's not just about how to get there but
once you're there how do you live and
work using the resources of another
world and then of course taking all of
that technology and all that capability
to mars that's the goal
in april nasa announced that it selected
spacex to develop the first commercial
human lander which would carry
astronauts from the orion spacecraft to
the surface of the moon the artemis
mission would be the first to the moon
since the early 1970s it would also be
the first time a woman and a person of
color ever walked on the moon but before
we get that far we had some drama on
earth to figure out
the announcement of the 2.9 billion
contract that spacex won enraged fellow
billionaire and space competitor jeff
bezos so in july bezos filed an
unsuccessful protest with the government
accountability office bezos then penned
an open letter to nasa asking the agency
to reconsider however the government
accountability office determined that
nasa was not in violation of the law to
award one contract and that the agency
was reasonable in its evaluation of the
proposals
undeterred in august blue origin filed
suit against nasa claiming the agency
was unlawful and improper in its
evaluation of three proposals for the
lunar lander contract
last thursday federal judge richard a
hertling ruled in favor of spacex and
set a protective order to seal documents
in the lawsuit would remain in effect a
blue origin spokesperson told forbes
that the lawsuit highlighted the
important safety issues with the human
landing system procurement process that
must still be addressed but it was not
immediately clear what safety issues the
statement was referring to and that the
company has multiple contracts with nasa
to achieve the goal to return to the
moon
jeff bezos responded to the news with a
tweet of support
elon musk responded with
a meme
nasa released a statement saying it is
planning to resume work with spacex as
soon as possible
you